on a un gros souci des cherry je
m'adresse à vous si vous voyez un garçon
pas très réveillé en train de se
promener dans les rues de boulogne
billancourt se troue le studio veuillez
indiquer son chemin cette personne
s'appelle bruno ont connu sous le nom de
doc gynéco il devait venir aujourd'hui
est le problème
je vais vous raconter qu'il est arrivé
au bureau à mon bureau ce matin à 9h30
pour être autre photo il était persuadé
que l'émission se passe il a pas il
était persuadé que l'émission était à
9h30 du matin
mieux ils étaient persuadés gagnant en
faisait télématin il était persuadé
qu'il était dans son bon droit de venir
ce matin en bureau et qu'il y avait des
caméras et il m'a dit je veux tourner
quelque chose maintenant je lui ai dit
oui revient tout à l'heure aux alentours
de 19h et il a pris la poudre et à la
bouteille son sac
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je les ai vus marchez marchez marchez
marchez au loin et j'ai crié dot et deux
heures après tel qu'un laurent entendu
dire oui il est 19h31 et nous n'avons
toujours pas de nouvelles de lui
la grande question que je vous pose
c'est va t'il venir où est-il que
fait-il et surtout dans quel état battu
là
nous a quand même laissé c'est bon un
indice à là puisque son assistant et
dans les locaux mais non son assistant
est là mais la insistant mais là
personne ne l'est pas c'est une énigme
vous avez deux heures jeux ramasserait
les copies tout à l'heure oui est-ce
qu'il va venir
on se le demande en tout cas sachez
qu'on avait même prévu une petite course
avec lui de mario kart et s'appelle
mario tard qu'ils étaient habillés ils
la tombe et pied ferme médoc n'est pas
là si doc je reçois la télévision
si tu te trouves pas ton domicile
appelle-nous au plus vite sinon vient
directement ta place est là ta place est
chaude
malheureusement il n'y a pas de boisson
il ya des gens qui t'aiment
oui doc on t'attend mais voilà merci m
[Applaudissements]
bruno à un assistant sont l'existant
normalement le suis
oui mais il a sommé son affaire pas
assez rapide